Now, we can use this equation and make a substitution. We can replace the
quantity x squared with a different variable that we'll call u. So, here
instead of having x squared, we'll have the value u and we'll square it. Here
we'll have minus 13 times u to the first power. Again, here replacing x squared
with our substitution of u. We're turning our non quadratic equation into one
that is quadratic. So now that we've got this quadratic, let's see if we can
solve it. What do you think are the solutions for this equation. Keep in mind
that you're solving this equation for u. We aren't solving for x, which was the
original variable in our original equation. We'll come back to that later. When
you have the answers for u, enter them here. Good luck.